اهلا بكم نبدا اولا مع الخبر الذي بدانا
به هذه
الجوله وهو اعلنت وكاله الانباء السعوديه
من ان الرياض والطيران اتفقت على استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح
السفارتين والممثليات الدبلوماسيه في غضون
شهرين وكانت الانباء الرسميه السعوديه
قالت ايضا ان التوصل لهذا الاتفاق جاء عقب
مباحثات جرت في بيجين مع الرئيس الصيني
اضافه ان المباحثات جاءت رغبه من طهران
والرياض في حل الخلافات بالحوار
والدبلوماسيه ونقلت الوكاله السعوديه عن
بيان سعودي صيني ايراني ان وزير خارجيه
البلدين سيجتمعان لترتيب تبادل السفراء
ومناقشه سبل تعزيز العلاقات واشارت لان
السعوديه وايران اتفقا على تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني بينهما كما اتفقت على
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه
تابعوا المزيد من بيجين مع مراسله الجزيره
شيماء جويي وايضا من طهران مع مراسل
الجزيره عمر هواش ومن الرياض مع مراسل
الجزيره بدر الربيعان ونبدا من بيجين
وشيماء جويي الحدث كله في بيجين فماذا
يقال في بيجين على هذا البيان وعلى هذا
الاتفاق
نعم زين العابدين رغم ان الحدث والمحادثات
التي تمت بين الرياض وطاهران كانت في
بلجيكا الى حد الان الجانب الرسمي الصيني
لم يعلن عن دور الوساطه الذي لعبه فيما
يتعلق باعاده العلاقات بين طهران والرياض
الى مسارها الطبيعي هنالك بعض وسائل
الاعلام الصينيه التي تتناقل الخبر مقتضبا
لكن لا تتحدث عن دور الوساطه ربما هي في
انتظار ان يتم الاعلان عن ذلك من الجانب
الرسمي الصيني حصنا وان الوقت قد تاخر هنا
في العاصمه بيجين لكن يمكن القول بان
الصين يبدو ان خلال الاشهر الاخيره خاصه
خلال ديسمبر الماضي حاولت ان تقوم ببعض
التحركات ثم يتعلق بالمنطقه الخليج
الفارسي واعاده العلاقات بين طهران
والرياض التي انقطعت منذ عام 2016 نتحدث
تحديدا عن زياره الرئيس الصيني الى منطقه
الخليج تحديدا الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في ديسمبر من العام الماضي عندما
انعقدت هناك ثلاث فمم قمه عربيه هي قمه
خليجيه صينيه واخرى سعوديه صينيه قد تحدثت
حين ذاك عن الملف الايراني عن الملف
النووي الايراني هي التي تم مطوله للرئيس
ايضا عن وقوفه الى جانب ايران ودعمه
لطهران امام العقوبات المفروضه على
الاقتصاد الايراني من الدول الغربيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتجدر
الاشاره ايضا الى ان العلاقات
وثيقه جدا يمكن استشفافها من زياره الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس خلال الاشهر
الماضيه الى العاصمه الصينيه والتي تعد
الزياره الاولى لرئيس الايراني منذ 20
عاما كانت زياره مهمه جدا بالنسبه لانجانب
الصيني الذي استطاع خلال ان يتحدث عن او
يقوم بتوقيع نحو 20 اتفاقيه مع الجانب
الايراني في مجالات الطاقه والغاز وايضا
مجالات الاقتصاد والتجاره ولكن الحديث
الاهم كان يدور عن اتفاقيه استراتيجيه
الشامله تجمع بين طهران وبيجين لمده 25
عاما تستطيع بيجين من خلالها ان تؤمن
الغاز والنشط الايرانيين باسعار زهيده
بقسم يصل الى 30% وايضا يمكنها السداد في
ظرفا يصل الى عامين كذلك كانت هنالك نقطه
مهمه تجمع بين العلاقات بين طهران وايضا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي طرح
الرئيسين لمساله شراء النطق من كلا
البلدين بالاليان الصينيه بالعمله الصينيه
بالتالي الصين هنا لديها علاقه وطيده
تجمعها بكلى البلدين ربما علاقه الوساطه
التي تريد تلعبها تقوم بتعزيز هذه العلاقه
وايضا تعزيز الشراكه التجاريه بين الصين
نتحول الى طهران
ومراسل الجزيره عمر هواش عمر البدايه
بدايه الارهاصات الاعلان عن هذا البيان
جاءت من طهران عبر وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
ثم التصريح لرئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الايراني لكن
الجديد في فيما يجري الان انه ليس فقط
اعاده العلاقات وانما ايضا الاتفاقيه
الامنيه ماذا تعني هذه الاتفاقيه الامنيه
التي وقعت في عهد خاتمي بالنسبه للطيران
تعرف زين ان هناك العديد من الاشتباكات في
الجانب الامني بين طهران والرياض خلال
السنوات الماضيه في العديد من الملفات
ربما الملف اليمني يكون الابرز لكن تعرف
طهران ان الرياض يمكن ان تكون بوابه لها
في علاقات امنيه اوطت مع الدول الخليجيه
في الضفه الجنوبيه من الخليج تدرك طهران
ان هذا الاستئناف العلاقات بين مع الرياض
يمكن ان يفتح لها العديد من حتى الاتفاقات
الامنيه مع بقيه الدول الخليجيه
يضاف الى ذلك الى ان هناك شاهدنا خلال
الفتره الماضيه مع ايقاف هذه الاتفاقيات
الامنيه بين الطرفين توتر في العلاقات بين
الطرفين حتى على خلفيه بعض التطورات
الداخليه في ايران كان هناك اتهامات من
طهران للرياض لدعم جماعات توصف هنا
بالهرابيه تشن هجمات توصف في الداخل
الايراني كانت طهران تتهم الرياض بدعم حتى
بعض القنوات الاعلاميه التي تقول انها
تحرض على الاحتجاجات والاحداث الامنيه في
الداخل الايراني لذلك عوده الاتفاق الامني
بين الطرفين وتفعيله يمكن ان يخدم البلدين
يخدم الامن في المنطقه مثل ما يقول بعض
المتابعين ليس يقتصر الامن على اتفاقيه
امنيه زيد البيان المشترك اكد كذلك على
تفعيل الاتفاقيات الاقتصاديه الموقعه بين
الطرفين منذ بدايات القرن الحالي وهذا مهم
بالنسبه لطهران نعرف انها ترزح لعقوبات
شديده يمكن ان يشكل لها نافذه اقتصاديه
ولو حتى كانت ضيقه لكنها تكون كبيره
بالنسبه لطيران في ظل العقوبات عليها وزير
الخارجيه لراني حسين امير عبد الله هيان
قال ان هذه الاتفاقيات الاستئناف التعاون
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه يمكن ان
يوفر امكانات كبيره للبلدين
للعالم الاسلامي وهو هنا يقصد تحديدا
امكانات سياسيه اقتصاديه امنيه يقول ان
سياسه حسن الجوار في ايران سوف تتواصل
وبالتالي تدرك ايران ان الاستئناف
العلاقات مع السعوديه يمكن يفتح لها ابواب
جديده في المنطقه خاصه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
ان مساحات التوتر بين الطرفين كانت تشمل
عديد من مناطق المنطقه الخليجيه اليمن
سوريا لبنان كل هذه المناطق يمكن ان تشهد
خلال الايام السنوات المقبله ربما المزيد
من الانفتاحات على خلفيه
استئناف العلاقات بين طهران والرياض
المنتظر الان هو لقاء قد يجري خلال الايام
المقبله الاسابيع المقبله بين وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد الله
ونظيره السعودي لاجل الاتفاق على
الترتيبات اللازمه لاستئناف هذه العلاقات
وتعزيز العلاقات الامنيه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه خلال المرحله وهذا اللقاء
مباشره اليه ايضا وكاله الانباء الرسميه
السعوديه وتوجه الى بدر ربيعان ما الذي
قيل في الرياض عن هذا البيان المشترك
بخلاف او تفاصيل اكثر عن ما قيل بجانب ما
جاء في بيان وكاله نشرات وكاله الانباء
الرسميه
الحديث عن ابرز النقاط التي جاءت في
البيان السعودي الصين الايراني والذي بثته
الوكاله وكاله الانباء السعوديه بخصوص
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه خلال 60 يوما فتح
السفارات والمثليات واتفاق على لقاء بين
وزيري خارجيه السعوديه وايران في تنفيذ
واتخاذ الاجراءات والتفاصيل لتبادل
السفراء ايضا السعوديه وايران اكدت على
احترام سياده البلدين عدم التدخل في
شؤونها الداخليه بناء على اتفاق الامني
والذي تم توقيعه في عام 2001 ايضا
اتفاقيات التفعيل اتفاقيات التعاون
الاقتصادي والتجاري الموقعه في 98 البيان
اشار على تاكيد السعوديه والصين وايضا
ايران على وجود اراده حاسمه لتوظيف كافه
الجهود لتعزيز الامن والسلام الاقليم
والدولي هذا الاتفاق الذي تم عنه الاعلان
عنه قبل قليل جاء نتيجه للامارات سياسي
طويل مر بثلاثه عواصم نتحدث عن بغداد
واستمر بدايات عام 2021 حتى اليوم هذا
الماسي كان يبحث عن حلول جذريه لاشكالات
متعدده بين البلدين لا الابراجها ما يمصفه
السعوديون هنا بالاعداء مباشره على
الاراضي السعوديه من خلال درعا ايران في
اليمن الحوثيين باستخدام صواريخ ايرانيه
الصنع خبراء ايران عسكريين ايضا البيانه
شار الى ان المحادثات بين السعوديه وايران
جرت في الفتره ما بين سته الى العاشر من
مارس في بكين برئاسه مساعد العيبان وهو
احد الرجال السياسيين الفاعلين في
السعوديه عضو الوزراء ومستشار الامن
الوطني في السعوديه ومن الجانب الايراني
الادميرال شمخاني امين المجلس الاعلى
القومي فيران ايضا
البيان لم يتم الاعلان عن الجوانب الامنيه
بشكل واضح وهناك ليس تفاصيل اكثر في هذا
البيان لكن دون ما شك سيكون في صدرتها كف
يد ايران على ملف الحوثي في اليمن ايضا
الملف لبنان ملفات سوريا ملفات الاقليميه
السعوديه والرياض كانت قد اعلنت قطع
العلاقات مع ايران في 2016 بعد جماهير
ومتظاهرين ايرانيين على السفاره في طهران
والقنصليه في المشهد تصاعدت حده التوترات
بينهما في ملفات اقليميه متعدده اذا ما
تحدثنا عن الملفات ذات التماس المباشر
بالسعوديه الملف اليماني سوريا لبنان
الفتره الماضيه شهدت بعض المحاولات من قبل
عده اطراف حراك اقليمي من قبل رئيس
الوزراء العراقي فتره ماضيه بدات منذ
ابريل العام الماضي
كان هناك حاله من الرغبه في حاله هذا
الملف ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان كان له تصريح سابق قال يامل ان تؤدي
المباحثات مع ايران الى نتائج ملموسه
لبناء الثقه واحياء العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين حاليا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
يتواجد في باريس سيعود منها الى الرياض
ننتظر الفتره المقبله بان يكون هناك عقد
جلسات وبحثات ما بين الجانب السعودي
والايراني للبدء في تنفيذ
ووضوح وبدء بعمليات التنفيذ لهذه
الاتفاقيه وطبعا هنالك مدى زمني حدد وهو
شهرا كما تفضلت بدل الربيعان مراسل
الجزيره من الرياض ونشكر شيماء مراسله
الجزيره من بيجين وعمر هواش من طهران